now we want to talk about your teammates
play a little teammate superlatives I
don't know if you remember I think The
Tonight Show last year said you're the
most likely to get carded when ordering
milk we're not gonna talk about you
we're gonna talk about the worst dancer
who thinks he's good on the dubs who is
it the worst dancer thinks he's good on
the dubs is probably Festus Ezeli what's
his go-to move it's just like some
shoulder thing that he brings out in the
locker room on the bench yeah we go we
go out so it's biggest teacher's pet
Ian Clark we we had a practice last week
and coach asked him give me some words
of wisdom on how do we can keep
ourselves motivating and and playing
well it was after the Spurs game good
just you know coaches just play like we
did yesterday coach like real
soft-spoken and like road roemello
everybody lost it and ran out the huddle
so he's one here with coach as I said
most likely to get emotional during a
romantic comedy movie surprisingly
draymond Green he's a very emotional guy
he's texted me a couple of times
watching either a documentary or some
kind of expose on one of us or one of
his teammates and he says and I said
it's here watching that watching your
story and all that stuff so romantic
comedy would definitely get to him what
movie do you always cry and a walk to
remember that's a solid one yeah that's
my go-to I think it's me every time
future head coach probably Andre
Iguodala
he's a very cerebral guy and they don't
use a cue for the game and they could be
really good at it most likely to
conveniently forget their wallet or
money out of the team dinner that would
be Festus Ezeli once again they stopped
most likely it's how many times has he
done it every single sorry guys don't
have it this one best chef on the team
probably Leandro Barbosa
he's the best Baker Baker he has some
homemade recipes that he always brings
in these little Tupperware containers
like the like team shower singing
superstar also Leandro Barbosa really
half the songs we don't know what he's
singing the reporter system is just a
roll of dice walk or in English but we
don't understand future celebrity
jeopardy participants klay Thompson
because he has the most random database
of knowledge I've ever seen the most
useless trivia in the world clay knows
it he he reads the newspaper all the
time he might do like the little
crosswords in there or something but
because he just has this this depth of
knowledge of things that you would never
guess that he would know I know you're
doing stuff with degree I'm curious most
likely to need to reapply degree
deodorant on game days or after
practicing I'm gonna go with everybody
because everybody could use some degree
yes sure who's the worst body odor and
he's not gonna like this again I'm sorry
Festus is all over this link stuff where
he's he's the MVP of cifaretto's right
now the motion sense lab doe wouldíve -
it's for something you know degree and
the motion sense lab with all the data
that we've talked about or analyzed with
how how I move on the court and I really
anybody moves we're kind of open enough
that that vote so it's it's pretty
informative of things that I do on the
court and how I play to be able to put
some some data behind it and knowing
that degree is the only do
that is activated with movement so goes
it sounds like he got a good guinea pig
now infest 100% he should be sitting to
see